Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier.
and welcome back to Super Mario Maker. We have 45 lives left...
-and 6 levels to go, so let's see if there are going to be big bastards to me.
and I..
*Whoa*
Ah run away! Wow, that was somethin'.
Okay.
Hey, you guys stay out of there. It's...it's still not your-
Oh, dammit I only accidentally did that!
Oh, shit.
Well this seems...odd.
How
H- whoa
Ah...
H- How..
Ooh.
AH
Woh.
Fuck.
W- AUgh
[Mark's mating call]
Whoa
Whoa, there.
Whoa, nelly.
What do you think you're doin'?
I'm not gonna be able to get one of those over here, so guess I gotta do this slow-methodical wall jumps here.
How am I supposed to get the right one if-
Goddammit, I know I'm supposed to bonko that guy.
But how? Goddammit!
Just..
Eh
I'm not
good
at wall
jumps
Fuck
F- Aww, fuck off!
That
is
so
stupid!
How
else
do you
do this?
God-
dammit!
Fuck!
me!
in!
the butt hole!
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
ok, well. At least I got that
I don't know what's happening down there
But it better be good
Woah
What the-
NO!
FUUUUUCK YOOOU!
Goddammit all that time
to get that and you're gonna do that bullshit
to me?! god fuck you
Fuck off!
alright.
Get that FIRST
Not that it matters, I'm gonna lose it anyways
But hopefully I ca- wooo Ah!
There we go
Okay, I can get through [Weird jumping noises]
Don't jump that yet. I don't want that yet
Oh! What the..? Oh.
I thought I killed him for a second there
and that would've, like, REALLY stopped me in my tracks
Okay. That's okay
Got him
There we go
WOAH!
Fuck
Off
Okay.
We're fine
Everything's fine
Let's just go through here
I got a 1-up!
and that's good
Oh what're ya gonna do to me-
WAAAAAAAH
okay.
I-I-I'm very scared
VERY scared
Hoh-kay
That was very scary
[Singing] You can understand my fear!
Woah-kay, I got that [Distraught Groan]
[Odd noises]
Woooah-kay alright, we're okay
What am I- what am I doing here?
Oh, I know what I'm doing here [Mark suddenly realizes his decision]
Okay. Nevermind
I don't know what I'm doing here
Ahh...bruff
Am I missing something here?
Okay. Do I need you?
Ooh, I might need this guy
[Inhale] Oh I DO need this guy
Okay, yeah, he's gonna break the blocks on the
ouuugh
ouuugh!
ouugh!
hey buddy
hey buddy- woooh
careful there.
hey buddy, you wanna play?
herr?
awww!
come on, come back
come back to me.
have to get over you.
there we go!
that's the right side, okay
now, this guy's gonna go
and he's going to do his damage
there we go!
yeah he did his.. deal
unless I'm supposed to go over there..
what are you-
d- uhhh I don't know if I was supposed to change that out
but I'll take it
just in case.
o-kay I was supposed to change that out but
didn't matter, apparently
k.
so I need /you/
ohhhh fuck off
with /that/ bullshit.
okay, that's done there
get this again..
okay.
that's okay.
'cause I can always get more.
ok, but now all of them are done
and supposedly -
is one of these an exit pipe?
maybe also an exit pipe?
shit.
God dammit
ohh fUCK
get off of me!
whoa fuck you
Whoa Whoa Whoa!
What the fuck was that all about?
Can I just-
whuuuuuaaaaaa
OH GOD
AH GOD
NO
GET OUTTA THERE
NOOOOOOO
OOOOO *voice crack* OOH
that's scary
ok, so, one of these
is the answer
ok, I'm a little confused-
OHHH!
they just need to blow up
Ohhhh
they need to blow up
ohhhh ok
there we go!
ok, so they just need to blow up down there
Kayy
I guess it's-
Whoa, what the fuuuck
I forgot I could do that
NOOOOO
That's not what I wanted
god dammit..
oh.
Well, that's not good
ok so as soon as that clears out
ahhhh, goodbye, goodbye, goodby-!
AWWW FUUuuuuu
fuck.
probably needed that
*sad sigh* ok
ooohhh no.
not choices!
I HATE choices!
*whining* I hate 'em
*still whining* I hate choices
ok there we go
At least i got that back
ok
what am I supposed to do about this?
this is a long ass level
No! I needed that
I need that
Fuck! I needed that
Aw, fuck, I'm dead
yep, I'm dead
uh boy
I did something very bad.
I- uh- auuhhh
*high pitched* but- it- but- it- uuuuaahh
*higher pitched* but- it- auuuhhh
*somehow, even higher pitched* but- it- AUuuuahh
kay, try this again
without the fire flower, apperently
Ok, this time we're gonna go up it
in in in in in IN
ok
i just wasn't ready for the door
I imagine all those doors go to the exact same place
Hello
Can i have that?
Oh boy
Whoa!
Fuck off
Ok, we got that
Got it, got it, got it
Ok, so that door in there might be the way
Yep! it's definitely the way, ok
Go through here
What is-
Well that's bullshit, ok
Ok so one of the - it must be one of the doors up here then
well.
Ok..
At least I'm in the right spot
Hup
Ok, so far so goo
Come at me bro
Come at me bro!
Whoaa, didn't expect that
Ok, that's not good
Wait, how am i su-
How the fuck?
oh no
Oh No
He's not gonna be able to get outta there and I'm not gonna be able to get around him
OH NO
OHH NOO
well this is... a conundrum
How do we fix this?
I think I'm boned
Whoa! there we go, yes!
PLEASE!
SIR
YES
OOOHHH
YEAAAHH
AND I GOT THREE ONE UPS
BABY YEAH
YEAH BABY
OH BA-BO-AH-BO
ok, so i made it through that level
ok that was convoluted, but not too difficult
and i had a lot of opportunities for one ups
It took me a long time to get through it, admittedly
But we're doing ok
So, long as we keep the streak going
and I avoid any too difficult ones
Because that is what I do not want
I don't want anything to do with that
we'll be fine
Fear the walking castle
I don't know - What does that mean?
Uh oh, well that ain't good
boin- Uh- I -  I don't know why that happened
Boink!
Ok, so now we got that
here, thank you, I was hoping for that
ok, woo, that don't look good
Uhhh, this is bad
Just gonna run for it
HUP, ok
Whoa
How 'bout, oh shit, god dammit
I can't even hit these
*loud groan*
*sexually 'uh'-s his way through*
*sexually 'uh'-s  his way through*
NOT ENOUGH... oh fuck
ok, so, apparently, I'm not supposed to try to kill both of them at the same time
if I'm, if I'm, trying to
This is gonna be a bitch.
I can already tell
This is going to be -
I don't even need that to get this
ok got that
we only got one going that way
Hup, fuck that was close
close
HUP
Kay, ah shit, I'll wait for the next one
Wait for the next train
fuUUUUUCK
How big of a doof am I?
The answer is 'an extreme'!
hup!
Oh, wow, I don't even know how that worked
Hup!
Ok!
That don't look good
Hup!
Ok! I'm trusting ya on this one
Ok! Trusted- trust is good!
I like trusting
Trusting is what friends do
And friends is what I have!
It doesn't matter if you give me a god damn fire flower
I'm still gonna fuck it up on the j-
*sad and defeated to happy and excited markiplier noise*
Whoa!
Whoa! Whoa!
Saved by the, yes!
Ohhh yes!!
Ohhh fuck
Ohh fuck you, stay away from me you god damn burning
Fu- oh you fucked me
You have fucked me
YOU FUCKED ME
GOD DAMMIT
I jumped right as the cannon ball went out
buh
It- fu- see just like that! ah shit
If i just- uhh
just like, embarrassingly, small jump
just like, "oops, ehh, i meant to do that, it's ok, i guess"
heh!
Ho!
Hey!
Yes!
Annnnnnnnnnnd yes
Yes! Yes!
Ok! Yes!
Yeeesss friendship!
Friendship is best ship
UHhh, one true pairing...
ok, here we go
hup!
Yes, please cooperate with me
I wanna be your friend
I wanna be there for you
in your darkest of times
I guess i don't need to panic all that much because it's not like they're going to go away if I keep jumping
so i just have to coordinate properly
and then i'll be fine
Yes! ok!
Then jump immediately
Go there, I like the sound of this
just be careful
Then boom you're done, you're done, YOU'RE DONE!
YES!
MMMM YEAH
oh that feels good
oh that feels good!
Oh that feels good!!
Oooohhh that feels good!!!!
ok
I'm gonna start the next one and then
see how it is and then go from there
hoo that feels good
That feels real good
I did that pretty well. Not to toot my own horn, but I did that pretty well.
I'm on level 13 and I've got 45 lives left
One mushroom One life
So I'm assuming that means I've gotta get through this in one try or else everything is gonna be fuuuucked
FUUUUUUUUUcked
ok
I can do that
Nahh dammit
There we go! Got it. I don't know if they wanted me to go this way but it seems like what I was supposed to do
ok, is this the one mush?
Am I one mush man?
oo- aahh - oof- fuuck me
ok thats a little odd. Am I supposed to put this there- ?
Waaaaah!
AAAAHH FUCK OFF
you bitch
bitch
Ahhh fuck
good god
AH uh
fuck
just gonna set this down
cause it's dangerous
I dunno how I survived
but I did
Boooink
ok, there we go
Now we got it
aaaaahhhh ok
I just gotta sneak through there very very closely.
I need not be so fricken' dumb about things and panic
Cause panicking is what causes my-
no.
but
no
no!
NOO!
NOOOOOO!
WHAT‽‽
WHAT THE FUCKING‽‽
god dammit, you sonova-
Why did it go in there I was right on the edge, dropping it
That's such bullshit!
I can get through this so long as you guys believe in me
Cause all I- All I ever wanted in life is to make you guys happy
With what
ah fuck
I'm all over the place
I'm all over the place with nerves
with everything
ok, I'm gonna try it from this side because at least it will be a little less dangerous
ok
Well thats-
Well I wouldn't be able to get through there anyway
How am I supposed to be able to do that?
Maybe if i grab this shell
and I toss it.. up?
noooo
Fuck you, god damn, damage boost [Mark wisely makes another wrong choice]
WHAT‽
FUCK OFF WITH THAT
OH YOU SACK OF SH-
ok, let's try this again
with the damage boosting. Whoa with the-
proper - NO GET- NOOOO OOHH GOD DAMMIT
fuck you
Ok. Stay. Dead.
ok
so I had to be damaged to go through there anyway
so thats good to know
Why can't I..?
Wuuh fuck
THAT'S NOT WHAT I WANTED!
Why would you - ? OH FUCK OFF
This level - this level is being a bag of dicks
This level is being the truest of dick bags.
100% dick bagery
I mean it's not hard. The thing is it's not hard
Like it- it- it
It seems like it was just made randomly and sporadically,  and for all I know-
WHAT WHY‽
I DID NOT DO THAT! WHAT THE FUCK
Oh my God you just set down right there because what the shit was that all about
It just randomly decided to sprint while I was on that one little block here.
and then it decided "hey, I'm gonna throw this"
And why is it not setting it down properly? There we go
hoo boy
This- this one's testing me
It's testing me good
Noo don't go over there. Good. Stay down.
ok
Now this time...
be less stupid about it.
That's not what I wanted.
So finicky! Ah shit!
AHHHH NOOOOOO
WHAT I COULDA JUST PUSHED ON HIM
I coulda walked right and I would've been in the clear
*loud grunt of annoyance*
Bag of dicks
Bag of dicks!
Bag of dicks!!!
Bag of dicks!!!!
Chant in the comments, everybody!
BAG OF DICKS!
ah
No! Come Back!
NO!
NOO!
NOOO!!
NOOOOOO!!!!
oh
Oh, it's the end.
Don't- don't fuck with me here
No!
Ohhh, if there were spikes or something there I would have been very pissed
Ok, that's all the time I've got for this episode of Super Mario Maker.
I got one one up off of that because they covered the top it.
You couldn't even get it anyway.
But thanks again everybody for watching,
and as always I will see you, in the next video!
Buh bye!
[contributed by MC-Dot]
[egg stirred and fried by Momma Markiplier]
[mazes sexually Marioed by yours truly, Big Poppa Markimoo]